[Música]
y como ya lo decíamos en directo a nos
vamos hasta Panamá para ahondar con
nuestro corresponsal Oscar zulmarana
sobre la petición de prisión para el
expresidente Ricardo martinelli la
fiscalía del país pidió la pena máxima
para él y otras doce personas por
supuesto blanqueo de capitales con
presunto dinero público para la compra
de una editorial en medios de
comunicación del país según la fiscalía
se habrían pagado casi 44 millones de
dólares Oscar según Fuentes judiciales
martinelli las otras 12 personas podrían
enfrentar entre 16 y 18 años de prisión
Qué pasó siguen ahora en el caso tienen
derecho a una réplica
sí lo primero es decirle que todavía el
juicio está en marcha el día de hoy la
fiscalía finalizó la fase de alegatos y
precisamente pidió esa sentencia de 12 a
18 años por el presunto blanqueo de
capitales en el que está incluido el
expresidente de la República Ricardo
martinelli y otras doce personas estos
alegatos fueron concluidos el día de hoy
por la fiscalía y luego continuó también
la parte de la defensa que se tiene
previsto que concluya este este viernes
la defensa del expresidente Ricardo
martinelli manifestaba que las pruebas
no son del todo contundentes y reclamo
también que no pudieran hacer
interrogatorio a los Testigos protegidos
que son en los que se fundamenta
esta acusación decía la defensa del
expresidente
con respecto a lo que sigue bueno va a
concluir la fase de la defensa de
alegatos por parte de la defensa luego
se tiene previsto que haya una sentencia
y en caso de existir una sentencia
todavía el expresidente de la República
va a tener la posibilidad de
poder solicitar o que se que se realice
de nuevo otro juicio saliendo en defensa
de lo que pudiera ser una eventual
acusación en su contra bueno martinelli
planea presentarse a las elecciones de
2024 pero también tiene otros casos
abiertos Cuáles son esos casos y Cómo
pueden afectar a sus aspiraciones
lo primero es decirte que este domingo
se llevan a cabo las elecciones
primarias de su partido realizando metas
y en las que martineles sería el Virtual
candidato presidencial para las
elecciones de mayo de 2024 pero como
bien dice esa parte de este caso de New
business que en los próximos días ya
debería haber una sentencia por parte de
el juzgado por parte de la justicia
panameña el expresidente deberá acudir a
otro juicio en el próximo mes de agosto
que tiene que ver con el caso
odebrecht sin embargo esto
evidentemente hay que esperar Cuál va a
ser la sentencia por parte del del juez
y la defensa procede con lo que vaya a
ser el resultado pero en caso de que
esto Avance en caso de que continúe el
proceso hasta que no haya una decisión
firme el expresidente de la República
Ricardo martinelli podrá aspirar a la
presidencia de Panamá